well I started actually in journalism
when I was I started the new york times
when I was 18 years old actually but
really got into journalism when I was 15
years old and had started a sports
magazine which was trying to become a
national sports magazine and frankly by
the time I was about 17 or 17 and a half
we had fallen flat on our face but it
was a great learning experience and in
fact it's probably the reason that I
even got the opportunity to step in the
door at the new york times i used to
read a guy named stuart Elliott who I
still read who's the advertising columns
the paper because before I go visit
advertising agencies to try to sell ads
when I was 15 years old I wanted to act
as if I knew what was going on and could
talk the lingo and so I'd read Stuart
every day and so when I was about 18 i
wrote steward any a letter and got him
on the phone somehow and said I wanted
to come work for him before before I
died I didn't know who he was or what he
was like but I was fascinated by what he
wrote and he was nice enough to let me
come in and come to work for free for
five weeks to effectively Xerox and
staple I used to literally cut out his
articles in the morning and put them in
a folder that was my first
responsibility so that's how it all
started I did not I did not my training
really was at the New York Times you
know when I got there I was literally
supposed to stay there for five weeks
and I got lucky like nobody you know
like nobody's business I was think was
the third week I was there I was in the
building had my Sudan must be doing
something right and a woman who had no
idea how old I was frankly overheard me
talking about this thing called the
internet back when we would write things
like you know modem comma a device that
transmits date over phone line this is
now in 1995 I don't know if that dates
myself or not but she overheard me
talking about this thought I knew
something about something and thought I
was a real writer person in the building
and started assigning me stories and I
remember going back to Stewart and
saying I'm going to do this and he said
this is crazy you know no high school
kid is going to do this and we didn't
tell her hold I was we gave her the
story they published the story and
there I am so